learning multiple languages at the same
time is not something I would recommend
to the average Joe but the reality is
that I'm doing just that I started
learning three languages at the same
time hi my name is Luca from Luca al.com
and today you're going to see how you
can learn one two three four or more
languages every single day so the
languages I'm learning right now and
every single day are Danish Greek and
Hungarian there's a specific reason why
I've listed these languages in this
order in fact every single day I always
start by learning the language in which
I have the lowest level in this case
Danish I just started learning Danish
some three weeks ago and I consider
myself a beginner on the other hand I've
been learning Greek for two years and an
guarantee for almost three and I have
reached a more or less a lower and upper
intermediate in these languages which
means that it takes much less effort for
me to learn Greek or on Garen for that
matter that it does Danish and that's
the reason why I do Danish first
truce
[Music]
establishing priorities is a crucial
factor in learning multiple languages at
the same time because as I said before
time it's not just a matter of time we
tend to use this word to throw this word
around but the truth is there's two
factors which are just as important as
time and which are energy and your
concentration and they're all entangled
the reason why I always wake up early in
the morning to lauren languages is
because I know that my energy is at its
top in the morning and at its lowest in
the evening so that's the reason why my
rule number one for learning multiple
languages at the same time is actually
wake up early and hit the books in the
language at its lowest level which is
Danish in this case those who've been
following me for quite some time I know
that I love ice meal which is a small
book a perfect learning resource for
beginners and in using that and I'm
applying my bi-directional translation
technique to it which requires energy
and most of all requires a lot of
concentration for at least 30 to 40
minutes
so after spending 30 to 40 minutes
learning Danish I can do a number of
things I normally organize things so
that I can do Greek after doing Danish
so that I can actually kill two birds
with one stone actually there's a lot of
birds that you can hear here because
we're shooting outside and the reason
why I as I said I do Greek is because I
know it's less than I do one garyun but
the good thing is that I can relax a
little bit more because I'm not using a
Simone anymore I still do listen and
read at the same time but sometimes for
example I talk to my i talky teachers so
it's a different thing um I started
really enjoying the language that's the
reason why this comes second is because
I know that I have to do it but I also
want to do it because it started being
fun so on a normal day I set things up
so that I can start working around 9:00
and it dedicate time to learning Danish
and then Greek but sometimes like today
for example which is filming day some
days are more intense than others so
when I have really intensive days I try
to make sure that at least I take care
of the last born of the family maybe the
other one's a little bit like grown-ups
and they think can take care of
themselves so to speak so don't beat
yourself up when it comes to learning
multiple languages at the same time if
you can't learn three languages every
single day that's not the end of the
world as long as you keep learning on a
weekly basis and the first one that you
born you should take particular
attention to
[Music]
so Danish and Greek possibly in the
morning
what about Hungarian well I've tried to
do one Garen after doing Danish and
after learning Greek but I've just
realized that after that I'm not I'm not
able to work because it's a lot of
intense work on languages first thing in
the morning and you know life gets in
the way I also have to work give lessons
teach coaching writing articles so I
told myself okay
so two languages in the morning when I'm
fresh and possibly one language in the
evening I take language courses language
lessons with two Hungarian teachers and
I try to talk to them around 1:00 and I
rehearse and I listen to these lessons
after after taking these lessons maybe
48 hours later possibly at night so I
just distinguished the Danish Greek
routine in the morning and then I'm
Garen in the evening on top of that I'm
also using a magazine which is called
modular worked on rock and the reason
why my routine with Hungarian is even
more relaxed is because again I have I
think I have an upper intermediate level
so I can be even more relaxed and it's
what I normally do to keep my in gearing
going and motivate myself is to you know
get get to go to Hungary on and off I'm
going to Hungary in a little bit so
that's more or less how I organize every
single day
one thing that I've been doing for years
and it really works wonders
is to keep a log book I open the Google
Doc and at the end of each learning
session I make sure that I go to the log
book and I write exactly the date what I
did and how long it took me
now for this specific project I have
created a logbook which includes all
three languages so every single day at
the end of the day I just copy each
entry and I transfer them into the
general logbook so that I can get a
clear picture of what I'm doing every
single day for these three languages so
the trick here is that if every day at
the end of a learning session you put
your entry and then you transfer all
these entries into the big logbook you
will see the progress that you're making
not in one not in two but in three
languages and that's an amazing feeling
just as the feeling that a climber has
when you know halfway he looks back and
sees the path that he's covered that's
amazing that's amazing for your
motivation because you always have to
remember and it can't stress this enough
that language learning is a marathon and
learning three languages at the same
time it's like you know running three
marathons at the same time you better
keep track of where are you going and
how much track you've covered so to wrap
up first is really important to
establish priorities I don't recommend
normally to learn three languages at the
same time but if these three languages
two or three languages are at different
levels that's fine
point number two is that it's really
important not only to organize your time
but to organize your energy and your
concentration and third make sure that
you keep accurate track of your progress
do keep one single log before each
language but also make sure that you
have a bigger logbook where you can see
the entire framework and the entire
picture that you are drawing for your
future so if you've enjoyed the video
please share it around if you haven't
subscribed please subscribe and click on
the link below because there's an
amazing article waiting for you with a
big surprise for the first time I've
decided to publish my Google Doc where
I'm writing each and every single day
what I do with these three languages so
you can see every single day you have
free access to what I do with Commons
and tips and considerations and
observations that are right there
every
single day enjoy
[Music]
you
[Music]